منافسه على الارض تتجه نحو الفضاء لتشتد
بين بكينو واشنطن فلا طالما كانت الولايات
المتحده والصين في تنافس على الصعود
السياسيه والاقتصاديه يابى الطرفان ان
يسمى صراعا طرق اليوم الى مستوى اعلى الى
الفضاء
تطوير الاسلحه على الارض لم يعد كافيا بل
اصبح التكنولوجيا الفضاء العسكري مفتاح
المنافسه
هي المهمه الاخيره لاستكمال بناء محطه
الفضاء الصينيه
لكنها احدى المهام الفضائيه التي تتخوف
منها الولايات المتحده في ظل التغذيه
المستمره والسريعه التي توفرها الصين
لتطوير قدرتها الفضائيه لتصبح منافسا لا
يستهان به في مجال هيمنت عليه الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لسنوات
اعتقد انه من الممكن ان يتمكن من اللحاق
بنا وتجاوزنا بالتاكيد التقدم الذي احرزه
كان مذهلا وسريعا
في الوقت الذي تتعاضم فيه مخاوف واشنطن من
التفوق الصيني سيكون استكمال بناء محطه
الفضاء الصينيه اشاره اخرى لامريكا حول
طموحات الصين المتزايده مع طرح احتمال
توقف محطه الفضاء الدوليه التابعه لناسا
الا ان المحللين يرون ان استمرار الرياده
الامريكيه في صناعه الفضاء تكمن في القطاع
الخاص المتنمي بشكل مستمر عكس ما هو الحال
عليه في الصين
جزر متنازع عليها في بحر الصين قد تصبح في
المستقبل نزاعا على القمر والمريخ وغيرهما
من الكواكب والثرواتها نظره بعيده
للمستقبل تدفع الدول لتخصيص ميزانيه ضخمه
للارتقاء بالقدرات الفضائيه العلميه
والعسكريه الى عمر العربيه